sometimes watching a movie just isn't
enough you also want to eat that movie
and that's why there's movie recipes
okay so today we're going to show you
how to make a Forrest Gump casserole
that is a casserole that tastes exactly
like the movie Forrest Gump let's get
started a good Forrest Gump casserole
starts with a good foundation of protein
and there's really no other option but
shrimp now we've got to add some
marshmallow fluff because let's be
honest this movie is sixty percent air
we're adding an entire jar of Cheez Whiz
because we want to recapture the film's
cheesiness but we also want to get a
hint of that bad aftertaste it's famous
for now for the secret ingredient the
stal joke now nostalgia flavoring can be
brought into a dish through a number of
different ingredients and it's highly
dependent upon your own personal
experience if your nostalgic about any
era of American history that era is
basically in Forrest Gump so likewise we
need to add something from the grocery
that calls for strong memories and warm
feelings of the past for you for me
there's no doubt about it
it's Tang now for you it might be I see
pops minute steaks or big league -
you're going to put it in the oven at
375 only to 25 minutes finally garnish
with a lit cigarette and enjoy
hmm it tasted like cigarettes
oh my god